c'est la une du magazine m édité par le
monde et une petite phrase de marlène
schiappa qui ont agité la sphère
politique la semaine dernière en 2022
c'est lui qui devrait représenter le
débat de l'entre-deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle et la mini
chargé de la citoyenneté parle bien là
de cyril hanouna à qui elle a rendu
visite plus d'une fois sur ses plateaux
merci de m'accueillir merci à vous déjà
s'il d'ailleurs elle n'est pas la seule
puisque cette saison plusieurs
personnages politiques tels que mounir
mahjoubi gabriela talent jean luc
mélenchon ou encore agnès pannier rue
nash et sont venus s'exprimer dans ses
émissions
cyril hanouna qui est considéré comme la
voix du peuple et qui aborde des enjeux
politiques et de société pour moi qui ai
pas un très haut niveau scolaire hanouna
arrive à poser des questions d'une
manière un peu plus simple on va dire
pour que tout le monde puisse le
comprendre
lors d'un numéro deux balances ton post
yann moix avait même déclaré l'élection
présidentielle va de gens ici franchir
les joues le danois qu une prédiction
qui dérange certains c'est pas
spontanément à lui je pense pour cent
alors cyril hanouna l'animation du débat
présidentiel
êtes vous d'accord avec marlène schiappa
alors on va voir déjà tous les extraits
1 qu'a eu sur sur ceux sur cette sortie
de marlena toutes les réactions première
réaction qui a été beaucoup au prix
c'est celle de gabriel atta le porte
parole du gouvernement qui est interrogé
sur france info par nathalie saint cricq
qui a déjà voilà année mais
l'entre-deux-tours nathalie qui devait
être avec nous d'ailleurs au téléphone
qui a pas pu au dernier moment et ses
animaux également pas ali baddou
regardez bien le malaise tusson tiens on
entend que marlène souhaiterait
éventuellement que le débat de
l'entre-deux tours soit animée notamment
par cyril hanouna
on cherche quoi vous cherchez quoi on
nous y serions favorables
c'est une manière
c'est dire qu'on va faire large non
c'est une manière pour sûr intéressé de
nathalie saint-cricq quand même rapide
j'étais en train de demander qu'on
remplace nathalie pas cyril hanouna
mais j'étais en train d'imaginer le duo
que cela donnerait à voir aux
téléspectateurs non c'est une manière de
dire je crois de la part de marlène
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'avec ses
émissions cyril hanouna board des enjeux
politiques des enjeux de société qui a
beaucoup de français qui regarde moi
j'ai eu l'occasion de participer à ces
émissions mais c'est pas possible c'est
pas pour discret j'ai jamais assez vite
j'ai jamais eu à m'en plaindre
c'est une manière de dire qu'il s'est
aussi d'une certaine manière installé
dans le paysage médiatique et politique
mais d'autres également c'est étonnant
que ce soit ce nom là qu'ils soient
mises en avant par la ministre de la
citoyenneté vous auriez pu penser à
quelqu'un d'autre mais je pense que elle
pensait elle-même à beaucoup d'autres
personnes possiblement des jean marie
bigard la tête de gabriel apte à
l'épaule on embrasse d'ailleurs jean
marie bigard alors je voudrais dire en
plus nathalie saint cricq on s'entend
très bien
je vous le dis voilà avec nathalie
j'étais à france télévisions avant j'ai
même pris son fils en stage qui était
très très bon c'est vrai vous êtes
témoin vraiment que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs qui est très sympathique et
ali baddou il était dans le groupe
canal+ voilà après c'est vrai que j'ai
pas compris la sortie d'ali baddou en
continu elle aurait pu citer un autre
non j'ai pas trop compris sur cyril
hanouna donc voix c'est un article sur
vous donc la wii elle va pas dire
patrick fiori
c'est vrai nom mais ali baddou depuis
qu'il est dans plus dans le groupe canal
il n'a plus toute sa tête lui aussi
alors rien d'autre mais nice qui a été
interrogé à la radio c'est jean-michel
bancaire le ministre de l'éducation qui
n'est pas hyper chaud regardait plus en
plus il sait que sur mon bâton fait
rarement des marelles ça ne chauffe pas
de garde ou contre jean michel blanquer
hanouna animateur du débat d'entre deux
tours de la présidentielle
cyril hanouna animateur du débat d'entre
deux tours de la présidentielle pour ou
contre
je suis vraiment s'en occupe plutôt non
mais
c'est pas par défiance vis-à-vis de lui
mais marlène schiappa l'a souhaité oui
tout à fait je dis pas que c'est pas un
débat à voir mais je sais pas
spontanément à lui que je pense pour ça
le pauvre michel vaucaire il vient il se
retrouve toujours en galère lui faire
mal ou les posent une question qui le
dérange on passe à dallas reparti vous
avez vous donner votre avis alors déjà
christophe barbier merci d'être là et
christophe vous franchement c'est une
mauvaise idée alors on l'a mauvaise idée
c'est le débat oui voilà le débat il ya
14 jours entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle il ya des dizaines de
sujets à aborder
il ya des publics différents à toucher
les jeunes qui votent peu les acteurs
économiques les plus influents les
retraités les travailleurs pourquoi on
fait qu'un débat depuis 1970 ces
quelques il faudrait au moins trois
débats comme aux états unis il comme aux
états unis dans trois styles différents
avec trois thématiques différentes
alors bien sûr un débat classique
institutionnels tf1 france 2 anne sophie
lapix gilles bouleau qui arbitre le face
à face comme on fait suivre à l'échelle
1 il faut ce deuxième débat chaîne info
ouais parce que les chaînes info peuvent
organiser une sorte d' interview un peu
mitraillette comme ça avec toute la
série de thématiques avec des
spécialistes pour bien voir si les
candidats sont prêts sur chaque dossier
seriez prêt à le faire ça non je pense
qu'il ya mieux que moi non je suis
éditorialistes notre opinion non il ya
des intervieweurs c'est vraiment un
métier très particulier
et puis à côté de ça il faut un débat
qui avait cherché les jeunes qui les
intéressent à la chose politique qui les
amène au vote et qui permettent aussi
aux candidats de montrer des aspects de
leur personnalité que dans un débat plus
est plus classique il ne montre pas et
de ce côté là bas dans ce troisième
débat pourquoi pas pourquoi pas cyril
hanouna en effet quand vous voyez que
naquit c'est vrai qu'il ya qu'yvan un
peu là dessus
qu'est ce que vous leur dites je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils regardent le véritable
enjeu
le véritable enjeu c'est d'arriver à une
très très forte proportion de votants et
donc d'aller chercher les
abstentionnistes les abstentionnistes
dans notre société ils sont
essentiellement jeune et souvent pauvres
donc il faut trouver des modes de
communication qui attire les jeunes et
ceux qui sont tellement désespérés parce
que leur vie est difficile qui veulent
plus voter et tourne le dos à la
démocratie
on l'a vu au moment dé gilet jaune
qu'est-ce qu'il faut inventer comme mode
de communication pour ça déjà faut
refaire toutes les publicités
présidentielle si vous savez les
publicités pas un pagne
c'est un enfer ne sont pas moins rude
tellement pas le droit d'être imaginatif
un support à la publicité comparative
pas demain que finalement on n'a pas
envie de les regarder donc faut changer
cette communication des despotes
officiel de campagne
et puis faut trouver des émissions de
radio de télé pour aller vers ces
populations là sans tomber dans le fait
que le guennic le jeu il s'agit pas de
se moquer de la politique et c'est là où
ça commence à être difficile pour cyril
hanouna
parce que si l'animal ces débats il ne
peut pas être l'animateur de l'émission
c'est pas son émission il n'est plus lui
d'un seul coup le moteur de l'émission
dont le moteur c'est la démocratie
c'est l'enjeu républicain ce sont les
deux candidats il doit se mettre au
service de l'instant démocratique qu'il
a l'honneur de quoi animer alors et ça
c'est un certain doute métier dès qu'il
ya un membre du gouvernement dans une
émission voilà c'est de dire du jour où
lui poser la question il avait également
agnès pannier rue nash ministre délégué
à l'industrie
on avait déjà reçu dans balances ton
post est dans touche pas à mon poste qui
est interrogé dessus regarder cyril
hanouna est un animateur reconnu qui a
effectivement une audience qui n'est pas
toujours accessible
les personnes à qui je parle aujourd'hui
sont pas nécessairement celles qui vont
regarder les émissions de cyril hanouna
et je pense qu'il est important que les
responsables politiques s'adressent à
tous les français mais c'est pas pour
cela que cyril hanouna a vocation à être
celui qui anime le débat du deuxième
tour je pense que beaucoup de grands
professionnels du journalisme l'isoler
se prévaloir d'avoir cette capacité
alors merci d'être avec nous c'est vrai
que voilà vous avez fait une sortie ce
matin qui m'a fait énormément rire a été
sur ces nous regardent et allez allez
partir en cacahuète interview c'est de
la petite phrase de la critique de tout
le monde c'est du buzz et ça montre très
bien ce que fait le gouvernement
il ne fait qu'une politique de
communication moi je vais vous dire à un
moment je me demande si qui donne les
directives dans ce gouvernement est ce
que c'est monsieur macro monsieur
hanouna je commence à me poser la
question alors née les gars niveau est
conseillère de paris pour vous c'est une
mauvaise idée c'est quoi c'est une
mauvaise idée de marins de chabat non
mais moi je vais vous dire je vous aime
beaucoup cyril vraiment et vous le savez
on se connaît bien
oui mais ce que j'aime pas c'est
l'insincérité fait tout comme gilbert
n'assument pas leur sincérité et moi ce
qui me déplaît c'est que j'ai remarqué
je suis vos émissions je regarde tous
l'un d'eux il ya plein de ministres ils
sont venus sur
émission ils ont dit plein de choses en
fait plein de promesses tous les cadeaux
au pied du sapin
et puis arrive au conseil des ministres
ils n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses c'est
à dire qu'ils se disent en fait chez
cyril hanouna on dit n'importe quoi on
fait un petit coup de com
et puis dernier ne tient pas il aurait
pas fait ça avec nathalie saint cricq
pas avec jean jacques bourdin pas avec
celui à saddam et est donc ça veut dire
qu'ils viennent pour faire de la com
je vais dire c'est pire que ça syrie il
ya une gratte et votre buzz mais je vais
vous dire vous êtes trop gentil de
continuer à les inviter
ouais qu'est ce que vous dites à sa
floraison ceni qui juge je sais pas moi
je vois pas pourquoi ce qui est laid
luna il serait pas demain qu'on dit
enfin un candidat sérieux pour
l'animation du second tour au fond je
comprends que quand on bosse chez
télérama on n'est pas envie de voir
cyril hanouna au second tour de la
présidentielle
je comprends moins sinon de quoi on a
peur peur de faire moins d'audience que
le record historique complètement nul
que ce qu'a fait le débat du second tour
le pen macron qui en soi était un drame
pour la démocratie que aucun français
n'est envie de regarder ce format ça
devrait inquiéter en tout cas qu'on ait
atteint son record ça devrait inquiéter
que finalement les français se disent
que ce débat n'est pas sérieux mais on a
eu sans doute avec le pen macron le
débat de second tour qui avait le moins
deux fonds qui était le moins qualitatif
où les candidats se sont le plus
injurier l'un et l'autre donc ça n'est
pas cela et pourtant cyril hanouna
n'était pas là donc moi je me demande de
quoi on peut avoir peur par ailleurs je
rappelle que ce sont les candidats qui
choisissent le duo de journalisme et
est-ce qu'on a peur alors que les
combats ne choisissent pas si elena mais
j'en suis le premier témoin ils viennent
a failli se bat pour venir dans cette
émission est donc pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'accepteraient pas que l'animateur de
l'émission à laquelle ils veulent
systématiquement venir à nîmes ce second
tour
par ailleurs il ya un certain nombre de
candidats qui à l'animation de 2,7
de ce second tour qui ont été rejetées
c'est le cas de crespo mora de
delahousse de julian bugier certains
étaient jugés trop anti le pen d'autres
pros macron d'autres trop jeunes
d'ailleurs donc à les candidats ils ont
leur mot à dire dans ce choix est donc
peut-être qu'on devrait leur laisser
dire ce que veulent voir animer puis il
ya un dernier point c'est que on
pourrait peut-être vous demander votre
avis parce que aux fruits votre mars
cave où la marque hanouna elle vaut plus
que celle de n'importe quel autre
personnalité politique est donc le
premier qui pourrait avoir une image
écornée en animant ce débat c'est vous
exactement alors j'en parlais justement
dans un instant je vais donner à mon
avis aussi là dessus juste avant
j'aurais qu'on écoute pierre henri
dumont députée les républicains du pas
de calais pour vous c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi parce que ces deux
métiers différents vous faites du
divertissement pouvait faire de
l'infotainment mais vous faites pas vous
n'êtes pas spécialiste de la vie
politique quand on a un mini un débat
qui est celui le plus crucial de la vie
politique française c'est le débat
d'entre deux tours on se souvient du
débat entre giscard et mitterrand
l'aller et le retour qui a fait basculer
l'élection en 74 en particulier quand on
se souvient du crash qui était celui de
marine le pen dans souviens aussi du
débat hollande de sarkozy avec la wii
parce que ça fait basculer les élections
et donc s'il y a en face de vous un
candidat qui sort une fake news
à mensonge et que vous n'êtes pas assez
préparés sur un sujet où assez calé sur
le sujet malheureusement sera pas
possible de le démasquer
à ce moment là oui par exemple nathalie
saint cricq pu la trouver préparer l
aller le même reconnu à la sortie de
l'émission qu'elle se sentait comme un
poireau c'est dire l'intérêt c'est au
fond la qualité de son rôle dans ce
débat elle
peut-être peut-être mais je pense
vraiment qu'il y a deux métiers et que
si c'est pas possible c'est pas de vidéo
qui devrait y avoir un week-end spécial
est vraiment voilà et à côté un mais
inférieure des besoins que durant la
queue durant la campagne des candidats
viennent ici que vous ayez eu à des pris
la décision d'interviewer l'ensemble des
différents comment un par un pour
creuser pour toucher une population
jeune bien sûr c'est aussi votre rôle
mais à côté animal d'animer le débat du
second tour qui est juste le moment le
plus crucial de cette élection
présidentielle je pense qu'il faut pour
ça que je vais faire ça mais bon ça et
avoir voulu dire c'est compliqué mais ce
qui agace même nom mais il ya deux
semaines de seconde tout à fait 14
heures les américains ils font pas car
cela entre les médias qu'un seul tour
oui il ya qu un seul tour la cassette
comme des candidates où le tueur et moi
c'est la leçon sur trois mois ce qui me
choque aussi c'est ton donné par les cds
c'est ça qui est déclenchée voilà ce que
c'est une autre marlène schiappa parce
qu'ils veulent taper sur le gouvernement
sera que c'est ça aussi qui fait que
voilà tout le monde l'a repris derrière
on va pas en dire oui est-ce que vous
bousculer le paysage
non ici à la meinau
et quand vous voyez les extraits vous
voyez que les présentateurs sont presque
pas de raison que symbolisait m nl 10
waouh
pourquoi parce que quand même
globalement monsieur le député vous
faites je trouve de la vieille politique
les présentateurs aujourd'hui comme
certains politiques qui parlent pas de
vie quotidienne
vous savez très bien beaucoup de
journalistes politiques je parle pas
pour christophe mais sont déconnectés de
la vie des gens et cyril hanouna il va
remettre le débat dans la connexion avec
les vraies préoccupations des gens il va
leur parler à tous
et quand vous dites non j'ai
l'impression aussi monsieur
respectueusement que vous aussi vous
avez peur de sa peur dans les vraies
préoccupations des enfants
cyrille weick sans pardon mais j'ai pas
besoin d'aller sur un plateau télé pour
entendre les préoccupations des gens
enfin vous savez je suis dans une ville
dense mille habitants dont j'étais maire
j'ai été élu très jeune à 26 ans dans ma
commune j'ai été élu et réélu parce que
les gens m'ont fait confiance et
j'essaie de résoudre leurs problèmes et
qu'à un moment donné moi la crise et
gilet jaune le premier jour j'étais sur
les ronds points avec les gens pour les
écouter pour savoir sur le plateau de
série
gilet jaune c'est le premier plateau
qu'ils ont mis au jour est pourquoi je
pense qu'il faut faire attention aux
caricatures vraiment sur de fines c'est
pour ça que marlène schiappa elle disait
coup coanimateur donc il faut un
animateur protocolaire et un animateur
populaire parce qu'il ya quelques années
vous étiez que dans le divertissement
et puis ensuite vous avait basculé dans
du sociétal aujourd'hui on parle même de
justice sur le plateau et c'est ici que
les choses se font donc vous allez
pouvoir toucher des gens des jeunes qui
sont les votants de demain et vous allez
permettre de résorber le le abstentions
voilà ça tombe bien le jeu il faut
additionner les publics sans mélanger
les genres l'intérêt que ce n'est pas
facile
c'est un défi aussi pour la personne qui
ait choisi parce qu'ils allient pas de
se transformer en un adieu mais elle n'y
arrivera pas il s'agit pas de faire ce
qu'il fait là tous les soirs parce que
c'est pas ça en effet le deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle mais moi je
pense qu'on peut arriver aux deux
additionnés les publics pour faire
baisser l'abstention et ne pas mélanger
les genres plutôt compléter le panel des
interviewés alors ce matin ça fait
tellement de bruit qu'ils en ont parlé
justement sur rtl isabelle ils ont
interrogé plusieurs auditeurs sur le
sujet voilà ce qu'ils en pensent était
dans les auditeurs ont la parole avec
pascal pascal praud l'année précédente
quand il ya eu les débats politiques
c'était difficile de tout comprendre en
fait en tout cas pour moi qui ai pas un
très haut niveau scolaire
c'est complètement difficile de tout
comprendre que hanouna arrive à imposer
des questions d'une manière un peu plus
simple on va dire pour que tout le monde
puisse le comprendre
pire la glace et c'est vrai que il sait
parler aux jeux de ce côté là il faut
pas il pour pas brillé mais je pense que
le maroc a pas franchement il faut
qu'elle arrête de dire des conneries et
quattro c'est bon la question pour moi
c'est pas dire c'est à nous n'avons rien
c'est dire que hanouna peut proposer
quelque chose de complémentaire et de
différent à skis c'est actuellement si
c'est pour avoir le même des bacs depuis
si c'est pour avoir les mêmes
présentateur qui ont fait sciences po
qui intéresse des gens qui ont fait
l'ena ou polytechnique je pense
qu'aujourd'hui fondamentalement la
population française sait recevoir du
changement j'aurais bien aimé en être
d'une très bien mais qui m'appelle ce
jour là vous vous dites nous isabelle
hachey je suis d'accord avec christophe
c'est un truc ultra corsetée par le csa
le débat de l'entre-deux tours c'est
impossible de s'éloigner de ce qui a été
décidé préformaté va se faire chier on
va vous mettre une personne avec 1000
personnes avec quand elle va être
forcément effectivement
de l'establishment entre guillemets il
va vous emmerder il va vous emmerdez il
va rajouter deux corsetage a dû
corsetage et alors qu'avec moi je
voudrais une soirée un immense balances
ton post puissance 10 là vous savez très
bien le faire vous êtes maître chez vous
voudrez ce très bel appareil dont la
reprenait j'ai pas d'accord et vous avez
mal même dossier du monde qui commence
en disant c'est un animal qui a été
nourri à la politique et c'est vrai et
vous l'avez prouvé dans l'émission et
moi c'est ça qu'on attend vous allez
effectivement à lier tous les publics
vous emmerde pas du tout alors je
l'écouté public et je suis sûr que j'ai
raison nous allons gérer alors monsieur
dumont j'ai pas une bonne nouvelle dit
adorons ça y est 4,8 et à sûreté pmp
vous entendez comment avec elle bah
c'est pas la folie républicains pour
revenir sur des pmp monsieur dumont
donne des leçons de communication à
cyril hanouna
c'est pas comme s'il avait coulé le
parti des républicains si on peut jouer
aussi on veut jouer sur ça on peut aussi
rappeler que madame ça y était candidate
aux européennes sur la liste qui a fait
le plus mauvais scores de l'histoire la
droite non mais c'est une amie amélie
non mais moi je suis assez d'accord avec
vous parce que moi ce que je trouvais
intéressant et là où vous êtes bon syrie
c'est que vous avez donné la parole coup
donné la parole au ministre mais ils ont
à tout la parole qu'ils veulent les
ministres donc tous les plateaux qui va
louer mais vous avez donné la parole à
des gens qu'on n'entend jamais et vous
savez que vous allez les ministres qui
font qu'ils prennent leur ticket pour
faire la queue à venir sur votre plateau
mais moi ce que je n'aime pas c'est que
souvent ils viennent pas pour se dire
tiens sur le plateau de cyril hanouna
je vais entendre quelqu'un que j'entends
jamais où quelqu'un comme responsable
politique il faut que j'entende ce
qu'ils ont à dire 'non évènement' disant
oh là là l'audience
olala les jeunes et ils essayent de
gratter votre boss c'est pour ça que je
vous dis grade votre base ils viennent
pas pour écouter et moi j'aimerais
plutôt que ce soit vous qui leur facile
hors leçons puis tant qu'à faire si vous
voulez vraiment compté dans les vapes
politiques allaient hanouna 2022
bon moi je vais pas voter pour vous oui
mais
on verra on verra mais moi je trouve que
tu en kata c'est donc apporter quelque
chose au débat et ce qu'ils viennent ces
ils viennent gratter ce que vous
apportez aux débats ils viennent pas
écouter les gens et moi je trouve c'est
plus important à chaque fois quand vous
avez donné la parole au gilet jaune
comme ça va donner la parole à tous les
gens à qui vous avez donné la parole
c'est eux qu'on doit écouter les
ministres les politiques les candidats
ils auront tous les médias qui veulent
non non mais ce qui est catastrophique
c'est que personne ne parle de
téléspectateurs bah oui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un jeune sur
cinq qui a voté à toutes les élections
car à moins de 30 ans à quel moment
alors tout le monde veut parler de la
jeunesse tout le temps sur tous les
plateaux mais personne ne s'en préoccupe
as tu y vas aller chercher maintenant
mais qui va aller chercher demain les
moins de 30 ans alors ça arrange tout le
monde
parce que ceux qui votent en réalité ils
font l'élection présidentielle ils ont
en majorité plus de 65 ans le l'âge
moyen ses 50 ans donc à un moment donné
va quand même falloir aller chercher ces
jeunes qui va les chercher
alain duhamel arlette chabot et quelques
rires si à un moment donné alors ça me
fait rigoler parce que quand on voit les
les visages mais n'a jamais réussi à
venir chercher un téléspectateur
américaniste où les sénateurs c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on ne reconnaît pas
la légitimité à cyril hanouna pour faire
un débat c'est ce ne comprend pas et
c'est justement non non ça marrant brio
il est on est on est d'accord que sur le
second tour séries tu pourrais rien
apporter parce qu'effectivement c'est
des questions qui sont définies c'est un
thème le chômage etc
ils n'apporteraient rien y'a jamais vu
un débat entre ont mis la porte était en
état j'ai jamais vu un débat en trente
ans où l'animateur aujourd'hui a dit
abbas a posé une question qui a mis en
difficulté c'est pour ça qu'il faut
changer
le débat est justifié et glen il est
très très bon et on l'a vécu ici
ensemble c'est que quand il ya un débat
de société effectivement il donne la
parole à tout le monde et s'est jamais
que d'un côté il ya toujours une
l'envers et de et le fameux coup le pour
et le contre
et effectivement le travail qui doit
faire il est avant et hélas il a un rôle
à jouer effectivement il intéresse les
jeunes et c'est là où il faut le prendre
pour ce qu'il est moi je trouve qu'il
est très bon dans ce rôle là oui il
fédère la jeunesse et surtout il parle
de propos de choses ne sont pas assez
peu voit la réalisation le plateau alors
il ya pascal praud qui a donné son avis
aussi ce matin sur rtl aurillac rapport
à cyril s'il est un animateur qui anime
des émissions c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les frontières sont parfois tenus entre
le journalisme et le spectacle et
l'animation je suis d'accord et vous et
balances ton post est un bon exemple
d'une émission où il est à la frontière
parce que on peut dire qu'il fait oeuvre
d'animation journalistique c'est une
assez contestable mais comment dire mon
adn est pas le même au départ lui c'est
un homme de spectacle quand même c'est
un animateur que moi j'ai je suis à la
télévision ou à la radio mais j'aurais
pu être à la presse écrite mais c'est
vrai qu'il a raison pascale clark
frontières et il est maintenant arrivé
oui mais pourquoi tout le monde en parle
parce que c'est plausible si c'était
juste une vanne personnes disent que
c'est une excellente idée que tout le
monde en parle aussi parce que c'est une
façon aussi de taper sur balles et deux
chats pas lui voilà un comité personne
n'en aurait parlé comme ça là les gens
se pose vraiment la question parce que
c'est un débat je pense que ça
permettrait de renouveler le genre qui
est complètement poussiéreux vous
poseriez les vraies questions et d'une
manière très intelligible lundi pour
tout le monde qu'il ya plein de gens qui
ne comprennent pas les débats quand il
les regarde et je trouve que c'est une
excellente idée franchement je voudrais
le faire avec un journaliste plus
sérieux effectivement en binôme alors il
ya nicolas canteloup que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs qui en a parlé dans sa
chronique ce matin sur europe 1 regardez
bonjour cyril hanouna salut salut menti
beauté et sa durée shireen shah passé
forcément ministre est là elle a une
super idée c'est que j'anime le débat de
l'entre-deux tours je suis d'accord avec
macro et un coin ça sera avec marine le
pen
bon si je peux pas je peux pas d'y
animer le débat du deuxième tour mais je
sais au deuxième tour commença au 2e
tour et en 2022
on réfléchit aux aurores les yeux je
vais me présenter et bébé aux attentes
je suis convaincre au moins aussi chaque
jour je dirige une bande de nuls procès
pour macro et qui sait que des
producteurs de rosé pas chaud ces repas
en 2022 et puis sérieux pour diriger la
france même jean michel maire il sera
pas pire que castex et il a des grosses
attaques dont jean-michel allait aller
voter merci nicolas catégorie géraldine
pons parce que c'est parce que c'est
marlène schiappa parce que les quartiers
son retour elle n'a pas beaucoup parlé
on parle plus parce que c'est vous donc
moi monsieur d'abord je voudrais dire
que je pense que serena est un sportif
de haut niveau
donc à partir du moment où il a en ligne
de mire un débat en 2022 de l'entre-deux
tours il va s'y préparer il sera préparé
comme jamais deuxième chose moi j'ai
parlé à ma fille parce qu'elle va voter
pour la première fois l'année prochaine
j'ai concrètement est ce qu'un débat
présenté par séries de la nature garde
ou est-ce que tu regardes léa salamé
est-ce que tu regardes boulot à ce que
ben non elle regarde vous parce qu'elle
regarde mais tp parce qu'elle est venue
à la politique elle a eu un éveil
politique
grâce à cette émission donc voila et en
plus je pense que ce n'est pas une
émission qui m'est ici c'est une
émission qui peut simplifier il faut pas
oublier que le premier parti aujourd'hui
des 18 24 ans c'est l'abstention
donc il faut juste penser à céder à ses
téléspectateurs aujourd'hui qui n'ont
pas accès à cette information politique
et qu'ils auront accès grâce à vous
voilà qui sera pas tout seul et qu'il
faut qu'ils soient tous les ouvriers
qu'il monsieur vous avez sous-entendus
qui se passait rien dans les émissions
d'un point de vue politique de cinéma on
l'a dit c'est le premier à avoir donné
la parole au gilet jaune sur génération
identitaire c'était le seul à faire
bouger les choses et informer le public
de cette situation qui était qui était
grotesque
qu est ce qui ressort d émission de
france 2 de tf1 avec des grands
journalistes où on donne soit disant la
parole au peuple
rien ce qui a manqué par exemple sur
génération identitaire c'est aussi de la
volonté politique et du courage c'est à
dire que génération identitaire vous
allez pas nous faire croire que le
ministère de l'intérieur que les élus
que les citoyens n'étaient pas au
courant de ce qui se passait ça faisait
des années non ça faisait débat si ça
faisait des années qu'ils avaient les
mêmes des trucs comme ça ex passé qui
avait des barrières au niveau des alpes
qui avait été mise en place des actions
il est un accélérateur de particules sur
le court mais parce qu'il ya une peur il
ya eu des heurts de dire tiens il ya une
prise de conscience qui a été fait et
parce que ces blacks ça fait de
l'audimat et tant mieux tant mieux que
sa phase de l'audimat c'est pour ça
qu'avant moi je suis favorable à ce que
les gens viennent ici comme vous
commencé à le faire quand jean-luc
mélenchon vient ici quand les ministres
du gouvernement réuni 6,2 match qui est
pas beaucoup de députés ou
parlementaires républicains qui viennent
mais ça sera après il ya le laisse le
sujet si vous allez c'est que ça a pu
permettre de grâce à l'émission
d'accélérer les choses mais si les
choses étaient connus
ça manque avant tout le courage
politique et moi je suis désolé de dire
ça mais le problème de l'abstention
c'est dramatique on l'a vu aux
municipales on le voit sur toutes les
élections
mais c'est pas un débat qui va permettre
de tout d'un coup à voir les jeunes qui
vont se dire on va se déplacer en masse
pour aller vous ils vont peut-être
regarder
peut-être mais c'est toute une éducation
qui a re faire auparavant c'est à dire
remettre l'éducation civique c'est à
dire faire en sorte de pouvoir dans les
écoles avoir une meilleure connaissance
de l'histoire de france de nos
institutions
enfin c'est ça aussi les rejeter en
rayon il ya et à bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie et des finances
qui a dit que c'était pas sa place de
venir dans une de nos émissions
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sa flore
en forêt on vous dit quoi vous êtes
d'accord avec bruno le maire ou pas
allez je pense qu'il n'y a que les cons
qui change pas la vie et que bruno le
maire comme tous les autres peut se
rendre compte qu'elle produit
particulièrement utile de venir dans le
premier talk des 15-24 qu'on peut pas se
priver de l'ensemble cette génération
qui pour la première fois va revoter il
est essentiel de leur expliquer par
exemple lui à son rôle
ce qu'il a fait au ministère de
l'économie pour sauver les commerçants
extérieurs pour donner envie de voter
pour la liste de mâcon j'aurai une
politique fiction plus que plausible
imaginez vous pouvez co-animé vous
choisi et qui franchement alors je vous
lis j'hésite entre yves calvi à vous
avez déjà réfléchi alors il faut qu'elle
vit parce que ça s'est passé
voilà way ou bien bah ouais ou laurence
ferrari harry qui est dans le groupe
pour la quête qui se monte entre
ailleurs sonia mabrouk serait pas elle
fait aussi très bien que j'aime beaucoup
et ce serait une spéciale tunisie
je verrai ça parle beaucoup des jeunes
mais il ya un autre électorat qui est
plus personne ne parle
c'est les classes populaires ces classes
populaires qui sont abandonnés dialogue
et vous vous leur parlez et ça c'est un
avantage les politiques ne leur parlent
plus ils sont en déshérence
ils sont perdus cyril hanouna leur parle
directement avec gilet jaune
il aura parlé je me suis entraîné sachez
le et à regarder ce que ça donnerait le
débat d'entre deux tours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu a compété je veux un peu c'est pas
mal l'un ou l'autre d'entre nous devra
être le garant de nos institutions
nous aspirons à cela vous avez menacé
les fonctionnaires il va défoncer dit en
permanence du mal des juges
dès qu'il ne vous arrange pas oui ma
[ __ ] vous êtes en conflit d'intérêts
c'est maintenant madame lowen la sent
pas et moi figurez vous je serai la
meilleure garante des institutions
oui je dis que votre projet il est
mortifère à je m'emballe à crespin on
met vraiment est ce que vous proposez
c'est la guerre des monnaies on l'a
connu vais quand même beaucoup moins
chaud mais aujourd'hui je dis juste que
vous disiez juste une chose regardez les
ils sont dans les campagnes dans les
villes parlaient de photos sur les
réseaux sociaux
je parle du quartier venaient encore de
montrer à quel point vous êtes indigne
ça ou ce mec callaway travaux vous
voulez livrer la france à une
immigration massive genre la foudre
rappelle-t-on perdre dans la foule bah
ils attendent que ça d'ailleurs on va
clôturer le débat là dessus parce que je
m'emballe aicto tabac
[Applaudissements]
mauvaise idée alors on va voir ce qu'on
pensait téléspectateurs tiens ça c'est
important
oui à 37,11 envoyé non à 63% c'est bon
sens ouais bah oui mais c'est nos
téléspectateurs avec mais a donc
forcément c'est bien dans votre rôle et
je trouve qu'ils ont raison pas merci
mais je pense qu'il faut savoir quel est
son rôle
je t'aime d'ailleurs que oui chroniqueur
se remettre en question jean michel
blanquer redevenir spéciale de marennes
pour marlène schiappa un jour devenir
influence hausse comme ça le sera invité
par gabin natale
vous êtes capable de ne plus faire ça
justement parce que ça c'est à nous à
tpm paix pour vous dire voilà il ya des
jeunes qui vont venir voir le débat
parce que je suis là mais je les amener
à la sortie à se dire la république la
démocratie l'avenir c'est important
c'est sérieux je vais voter dimanche
bien sûr mais aussi viennent en se
disant ah tiens on va bien s'amuser
cyril hanouna va pas se moquer des
politiques et ils vont sortir en disant
oui les problèmes sont sérieux l'avenir
est grave je vais voter
est-ce qu'il n'a aucun passé ce soit il
et c'est ce qu'on fait dans balance
composent séquence oui voilà après après
j'ai je vous dire moi je vais je vais
répondre à la question le débat d'entre
deux tours franchement non j'ai des
émissions présidentielle oui mais voilà
des spéciales pour les présidentielles
oui ça à fond on va essayer d'en monter
je vous le dis dès l'année prochaine et
c'est sûr voilà avec les candidats ça
oui à fond le débat d'entre nous
tournant après christophe vous dit un
truc grèce est quand même il faut poser
la question si voilà de de pouvoir faire
du divertissement et du gros
divertissement et derrière de faire
quelque chose de plus sérieux est
d'amener les jeunes à voter
je pense qu'il faut coupler un petit peu
les deux sinon les jeunes ne viendrait
pas du tout quand je vois les émissions
qui sont faites voilà sur le service
public vous dis-je en plus je trouve que
voilà et son fait parce qu'ils ont un
cahier des charges qui est beaucoup plus
compliqué que le nôtre c'est vrai que
les jeunes ne viennent pas du tout parce
que c'est rébarbatif c'est que c'est
chiant voilà donc il faut amener quand
même un petit peu de malice venir sont
comme on le fait dans btp ou voilà on
arrive à avoir un débat qui fait avancer
les choses très souvent mais dans lequel
on arrive à avoir un poil de
divertissement quand même pour avoir les
plus jeunes qui nous regardent